[Music]
welcome back so we just have derived
this this nice interpretation of the
singular value decomposition in terms of
the eigenvalues and eigenvectors of
these correlation matrices these column
wise and row wise correlation matrices
and I told you in general this is not
actually how you want to compute the SVD
there's other more efficient ways of
computing it but this is a nice
intuitive way to understand it now
that's not entirely true there are
occasionally times where you would
actually use this to compute the SVD for
example if your data matrix X is so very
large that you can't actually compute it
or store it all in memory okay and so
there's something called the method of
snapshots the method of snapshots and
this was invented in 1987 by C ravitch
in the field of fluid mechanics so he
introduced this method when this is
fluid flow data that was so so big that
you couldn't actually store it in memory
to compute a QR factorization and
interestingly just aside he introduced
the method of snapshots in exactly the
same year that he introduced his famous
eigenfaces paper where he showed that if
these column vectors are human faces you
can use the SVD to build a basis of
eigenfaces and then use that for
classification and things like that so
this is a pretty amazing year for for
data science yurevic introduced both the
snapshot the method of snapshots and
showed that you could you could compute
eigenfaces from from data ok so again I
just want to be very clear in the vast
majority of cases I do not recommend you
compute the SVD using correlation
matrices but in the rare occasion that
this matrix is so big you can't load it
in memory here's what you can do if you
can't load all of X into memory what you
can do is load call it two columns at a
time let's say the first column and you
take its dot product with itself then
you load the first column in the second
column you take its dot product the
first column in the third and so on and
so forth so if you can load two
vectors into memory you can compute this
correlation matrix okay it's very
time-consuming it'll be very slow but
you could build this by loading two
vectors at a time and computing their
inner products and the resulting little
M by M matrix is small enough that you
can put it in memory and compute its
eigen decomposition so if the if the
data is so large what you can do is you
can compute x transpose x element by
element to call it two vectors at a time
you use that decomposition to get your V
and your Sigma hat your V and your Sigma
hat matrix and then you can solve for u
hat using these so if you assume that x
equals u hat Sigma hat V transpose you
can solve for u hat by inverting the V
and then inverting the Sigma hat so this
equals x times V times Sigma hat inverse
okay and you can compute this this
matrix u hat again you can load just
pieces of this matrix X at a time and
compute this efficiently if this is
really really really really big and so
that's the method of snapshots where you
do compute this correlation matrix the
small little M by M and the fact that it
has the same eigenvalues as the big one
allows you to approximate those left
singular vectors these really tall
eigenmodes using your original data
matrix and then these that you computed
from your small correlation matrix okay
again not recommended if you can get
away with computing the SVD a different
way using for example the QR
factorization or randomize techniques
that we'll talk about later do that but
I wanted to show you this method of
snapshots for completeness okay thank
you